Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie!
Merry Christmas, this is going to be my Flash
Episode 9 video.
And yeah, I know it's going to be off the
air for a couple weeks, but don't freak out.
It's coming back January 19th, the same week
as Arrow and Legends of Tomorrow.
So just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen the episode yet and there's a new round
of the reverse flash ring giveaway all you
have to do to enter that is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video so why don't
we go ahead make this top 10 just because
is the mid season finale big freaking episode
fattening the flash up like a goose starting
with number 10 Joe and Iris talk about what
to get Barry for Christmas my dad gave me
this watch because I could never be on time
gifts that always have secret meanings I like
that idea everything everyone else is getting
for each other is some coded metaphor for
something that's exactly how fanfiction and
fan theories start this episode in particular
did a really good job of showing the dichotomy
between like that the family stuff that happens
around the holidays and the relief WTF villains
flash stuff that's happening to you the rogues
revenge you have the zoom stuff but then you
have the family drama holidays good for some
people really bad for others onto my number
nine WTF the actual opening of the episode
hands-down my new favorite opening to a holiday
themed episode Merry Christmas Sumas like
all totally spared Jesse quick but you have
to help me with something that even if it
was in a flashback it was happening in real-time
it still takes Harrison wells the entire episode
to kind of figure out why zoom wants Barry
so bad he's pushing him all a Hunter Zolomon
and Wally West to get faster not so that he'll
be better like it was in the comics but so
that he can drink his speed force milkshake
out there will be speedster blood on the number
eight though Jay Garrick messing with Caitlin
so very clearly they were setting them up
for relationship early in the season so Caitlin
is probably just as awkward as Cisco or Barry
you can argue about which is the most awkward
I think Cisco used to be a little bit more
awkward before Hawkgirl but I just love some
of their dialogue Christmas what's Christmas
and Caitlin just like totally buying it she's
just being super literal like old Christmases
the celebrations like Sears eight norms I'm
just joking we actually have Christmas on
earth two also turns out that they have the
Godfather on earth 2000 of the great light
to every Earth has the godfather there is
a lot of relationship stuff happening on the
show right now I feel is the most enjoyable
run right now are least in this episode was
Caitlin and Jay just because it's the perfect
the matted cheese ball I do love the comedy
of Barry and Patty wearing matching ugly Christmas
sweater just because it's so terrible sounding
the problem with jokes like that though is
that most people miss it like most people
watch that and take it literally like all
that stupid they're wearing matching Christmas
sweaters without realizing that it's supposed
to be stupid like as being stupid on purpose
part of the fun of some of the humor like
the really awkward you know nerdy geeky humor
between like Caitlin J Cisco Barry Patty is
that it's very self-aware like were the biggest
nerds in the world lushes have some fun but
on my number seven WTF weather wizard breaks
out Captain cold in the trickster from prison
in the trickster all man is so much fun seeing
more camelback this year even though his role
was a little bit smaller than it was last
time is just so bad she crazy especially the
broadcast that he does later like pretty much
every time he has a line of dialogue he has
some sort of Christmas pond and I know a lot
of people watch Mark Campbell as the trickster
know like always sounds just like the Joker
but if you actually listen really carefully
the the way he inflicts his voice a little
bit differently he doesn't go quite as high
as the Joker goes the Joker's laugh goes into
like a much higher register either way I think
people is really pumped to see them back really
the twist here is that weather wizard which
is breaking Captain cold out because he owed
him one from last year the Captain cold is
kind of on a hero Arik it is more of an antihero
I meet is not a true hero because he still
cannot hates himself like most villains do
like he loathes himself little bit but I think
he uses the fact that he owes the flash one
for saving his sister to do something good
without actually having to say that he's doing
something good like he wants to help Barry
a little bit so it's like okay all this I'll
use this to clear the books also cool thing
to note that a lot of the rogues know all
about Barry being taken down by zoom earlier
and onto my number six WTF Patty learns that
Mark Martin the man who killed her father
is back in goes a little crazy it's a really
intense seen the comedies kind of tongue-in-cheek
this Patty like I don't have the time to tell
you I can't say it fast enough there is like
that's that's kind of ironic that Patty does
not know that Barry knows about Harrison wells
of earth two or all the metahuman's I know
were all kinda wondering how Patty's going
to figure out if she's gonna figure out herself
for berries gonna tell her when I do think
it ends up happening I think it will be a
spectacular explosion Barry's face and then
the best possible way but for most of this
episode Patty had her own art to go after
Mark Martin doubt that was her whole thing
in this episode she only crossed paths with
the flash briefly but we do get to find out
number five WTF Patty and the flash versus
all the dreidel's we do get to find out that
Patty has a lot of anger inside of her over
her father died she blames herself I was the
one that killed him this was price some of
the best character development of the Patty
character has gotten all season I'm afraid
of the guys that I really like finding out
how angry I am she makes it sound like she's
keeping this secret from Barry but the boy
that she really likes but I don't really consider
it a secret it's on par with like the zoom
Harrison wells secret or Barry keeping his
secret from Patty but everybody has their
secrets like Wally West for instance on my
number five WTF Iris freaks out goes crying
to bury and they talked to Joe about Wally
West boom big reveal you have a son this is
like the moment where you turn to whoever
you're watching the episode with and yell
at them you know I'm not crying you're the
one that's crying most cry were the moment
of the episode Wally is short for Wallace
it's what we were going to name you if you
had been a boy based on their conversation
they make it sound like Wally doesn't know
anything about Joe doesn't know anything about
Iris figures is breaking down throughout the
episode just feeling like he hasn't been there
for his son when he needed them Barry comforts
them and then finally later in the episode
onto my number four WTF Joe gives Barry the
watch I always meant to give this to my son
I love you here you go it's that you know
just another big cry were the moment in the
episode Jesse Martin the actor was just on
fire this week he was amazing I was a little
surprised that he gave Barry the watch though
I figured that he would give it to Wally West
but I guess were gonna see how that relationships
can apply out over the back half of the season
but I think him giving the watch to bury it
just to wait for him to show that you're my
son just as much is Wally is on the my number
three WTF team flash disables all the bombs
and Barry stops Patty from throwing her life
away by killing weather wizard so amazing
visual effects sequence followed by amazing
WTF drama twist ending his life will also
end your life all the things that you love
now will be taken away from you who else thought
that Barry was gonna rip his mask off to stop
her just distal like stopper cold in her tracks
that she would pull the trigger Mark Hamill's
reaction is just priceless to he's so bipolar
the character so bipolar this is so beautiful
like he's full of so much emotion and so much
evil at the same time is so funny I love the
Christmas fireworks of all the presidents
getting sucked up into the earth two portal
to their Christmas fireworks all over the
sky and we get a new light saber on the show
I see you've constructed a new light saber
periods force lightning who warred better
Luke Skywalker taking force lightning or Barry
taking force lightning it would not be a Mark
Hamill episode if there were some Star Wars
jokes and their what a coincidence that this
episode came out the same month that new Star
Wars is coming and also during their whole
firefight there was like another Easter Egg
for the comic was Barry running on the helicopter
blades and weather wizard levitating himself
right out of the comics on my number two WTF
surprise Christmas guest Wally West what the
hell's going to happen now so a Joe being
super excited to meet him and Wally seeming
fairly well-adjusted I guess in the short
scene that we've seen him in it seems like
it's going to be a fairly positive thing but
it's gonna be a lot of fun seeing all the
other characters to adjust them especially
Iris and Joe does anybody else think the Joe's
gonna go into dad overdrive just to make up
for all the years that he and Wally didn't
know each other the speaking of dad's going
overboard for their children onto my number
one WTF Harrison wells agrees to help fatten
up Barry so that zoom can take his speed force
a lot more speed force than he normally would
be able to take another great appearance by
Jesse quick but we finally learn like what
zooms big plan for Barry as he does is the
want to kill him to kill him he wants to take
his speed force to make himself more powerful
now giving and taking speed force is a big
thing in the comics that actually started
around the Wally West era so zoom seems like
a cross between the Edward Clariss reverse
flash and Hunter Zolomon wanting to make the
flash better but also wanting to take his
speed effect after the seams I'm leaning a
little bit further away from Henry Allen being
zoom just because it's zoom were Henry Allen
and then he would know that Barry is his son
of Earth one and no matter what the black
hole that is his heart looks like the he would
probably still not want to kill his son no
matter which earth he was from let me know
in the comments what was your favorite moment
from this episode what you think about Wally
West and how long do you think it's going
to be before team flash finds out that Harrison
wells is going to doublecross them do you
think that Harrison wells will come clean
to bury I make it because Barry essentially
came clean two Harrison wells without him
knowing about it like he he was using Harrison
wells to forgive you bar Thawne just like
Joe letting go of his hate for his ex-wife
universally he could let in the love for Wally
West so Barry let's go his hates like a little
is good things back into his life maybe Harrison
wells of earth two will do the same thing
but in terms of midseason finale's I feel
like this is my new favorite right now want
to see the agent to shield delivers his big
of a WTF supposedly a well so I'm I'm pretty
excited about that was can happen next is
is actually do have a bunch of marble bonus
videos is some Doctor Strange strange stuff
some Captain America Civil War agent to shield
midseason finale but there's also a trailer
for the rest of the season of the flash so
try to do that sometime this week to don't
forget there's also the arrow midseason finale
so couple really huge things coming in the
next day or two just in case you haven't seen
it I did a Supergirl video for the big character
reveal I guess and just careful in case you
haven't seen it yet, and click here for that
all about the character from the comic books
and you can click here for my game of thrones
season 6 teaser video thank you so much for
watching everybody high five and I'll see
you tonight!